[Music]  huh  hey miss Potts if you find this  recording don't feel bad about this part  of the journey use the end  [Music]  just for the record being adrift in  space with zero promise of rescue is  more fun that sounds food and water ran  out four days ago  oxygen allowed out tomorrow morning back  then when I drift off I will dream about  you  it's how I see you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  danos did exactly what he said he was  gonna do  he wiped out 50% of all living creatures  we lost all of us  the lost friends who lost family  we lost a part of ourselves  this is the fight of our lives this is  gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I  don't know what I'm gonna do if it  doesn't  hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we  met a few years ago at the airport in  Germany my job really big it's just an  old message I know you know that's right  that's me can you buzz me  you